[Music]
hey little liars I'm Liana Galera and
I'm Katie Kraus and we thought that
today we would take you guys down
rosewood memory lane we know that many
of you have no idea what happened before
so Katie and I are going to take on the
task of recapping everything you need to
remember in two minutes let me do it
okay so the show starts one year after
Ali DiLaurentis is disappearance yes and
Aria returns from Iceland she's
reconnecting with all the rest of the
liars because they've drifted apart a
little bit and then they all realize
that they've been getting the same
messages from dun-dun-dun hey Emily and
I aren't the only ones who got messages
from a are we and of course we cannot
forget that aria and Ezra met before she
realized that it was her English teacher
we also met Caleb season one yes and
even Hanna hit it off right away
he eventually moves into her basement
and then of course we were introduced to
Toby in the very beginning but he was
Jenna's stepbrothers a little creepy we
didn't know his vibe Ali's body is then
discovered and now her family holds a
memorial a funeral if you will all the
little liars attend fast forward a few
seasons it turns out that was actually
Bethany's body
oh gosh new young this show Bethany
young I don't know and of course who can
forget Melissa Hastings who randomly
ended up marrying Ian after she broke up
with Wren after Spencer and red hooked
up there's also that whole nhe Club
thing and then Ian threatens Spencer and
then someone actually pushes Ian off the
bell tower
so after dealing with all the turmoil
and season one the girls then go to
therapy to work out their a issues now
we also meet Jason DiLaurentis who is
Ali's older brother and let me just
point out it's a completely different
Jason than we met in season one it turns
out that we find out the cause of death
of the mysterious body and it was blunt
force to the head with a shovel but we
at this point still are thinking that
it's Alison's body and also a frames the
girls yes you see helicopters and lights
and it's this huge chaotic scene
and of course we've got to talk about
the Jenna thing
and we come to find out that Ali and the
girls were actually responsible for the
fact that Jenna went blind
but the biggest reveal Mona is a
original a original original egg who
tried to run over her best friend Hannah
with a car how could we forget the
introduction of Cece Drake I'm CeCe
she met Mona and Radley and that is
where she befriends Cece and if you're
not already confused enough let's not
forget when Toby joined the a-team dun
dun dun but it was only to get close to
a so that he could protect Spencer we
cannot forget the biggest red herrings
of the season red coats
while we were trying to figure out is a
the same thing as red coat is Ali red
coat and Sara Harvey red coat are they
all red Co who's Sarah they are all kind
of red coat who is Sarah Hart I still
don't know who you are
so then we realize there's a whole new a
who is stolen the game from Mona and of
course we cannot forget our brief but
memorable visits to the town of
Ravenswood in Ravenswood is where we
realize are you ready that Ali's alive
did you miss me as we find out that Ali
is alive we are then tricked into
believing that Ezra is actually a but it
turns out he's actually just writing a
book about the girls poor Ali home girl
could never catch a break because by the
end of that season her mom was some
knocked over the head and buried Ali
then returns to Rosewood high and thus
begins Emison so let's fast forward a
little bit cuz then we see Mona she's in
her bedroom and we see big a attack her
murder her she was really taken though
yeah the dollhouse
done Ali was charged with Mona's murder
and then all the other girls were
charged with tampering with evidence big
a kidnaps the girls on their way to
prison put into a doll house dressed up
like little dolls and that's when we saw
Mona dressed as Ali Rosewood police does
not find the girls because they're so
bad at their jobs who finds the girls
Toby and Caleb and then we realize who
big a is Charles DiLaurentis
actually Charlotte DiLaurentis who is
actually wait for it Cece Drake don't be
so dramatic Ali CeCe
that also is one of the most frustrating
finales ever because for that to be who
big a was and then we find out who black
widow was aka one of the Redcoats Sara
Harvey you saw the body right who is
Sara Harvey I smelled are you are Harvey
we don't know who you are
they sent Charlotte to go get better and
bond with Alison spite the fact that her
brother slash sister spent the last
however many years torturing the hell
out of her Charlotte is then murdered
after all of that
so because of Charles is death yes we
have a new villain this person has then
emerged as a d moving forward here is
where we left off Spencer is shot Mary
Drake shows up she basically tells
Spencer we then find out that Ali is
pregnant we don't know who the father is
but also what's convenient is the fact
that Emily had donated her eggs a little
while ago and they are missing and also
ad picks up Jenna
puts her in the back of a van and that's
essentially where we left off and there
you have it except that wasn't two
minutes definitely not two minutes but
there's just so much craziness exactly
and there's so much craziness to come
keep it locked to each hand line so
we're gonna be breaking down all the
biggest moments from these final ten
episodes and of course let us know who
you guys think ideas sent us over your
tweets with all of your theories and
we'll talk to you over there later Liars
bye guys
you